bonsoir gregory charles bon soit on va
retrouver à l'amphithéâtre fernand
lindsay à joliette où vous présenter ce
soir un spectacle 22,69 hommage à ou aux
titres à écouter tout comme moi vous
étiez trop jeune pour assister au
festival tout cas moi c'est un événement
qui vous fascine
dites nous pourquoi 50 ans plus tard ça
fascine toujours autant selon vo je
pense parce que c'était inattendu
il ya des gens qui ont décidé
d'organiser un festival ils ont lancé
mais ils ont lancé des lignes à l'eau en
espérant que les gens allaient répondre
à leurs attentes étaient limités au
départ et puis ensuite de sont leurs
attentes ont grandi puis elle m'a
peut-être en terme de programmation ils
ont pas tout à fait réussi à attirer les
gens qui le souhaitaient mais en terme
de public
l'autre chose qui fasse il ya deux
éléments d'après moi qui définissent les
années 60 pour lier pour les américains
et un peu pour le monde et ces deux
éléments c'est l'ambition de faire
quelque chose en terme collectif
je pense que ce soit cette ambition
cette mère compréhension de la force de
l'humanité qui suit les restes de la
deuxième guerre mondiale puis et puis de
la guerre froide ça s'est exprimée à
travers le désir d'aller sur la lune et
donc à l'été 2009 169 on réussisse à
cette opération de faire quelque chose
pour l'humanité de ne plus grand que ce
qu'on pensait pouvoir réaliser et
l'autre élément c'est la force de la
contre culture
la force de la résistance à l'ordre
établi une force qui s'exprime de plein
de façons à littérature de façon
politique hostile aux états unis mais
qui s'expriment tellement bien travers
les arts et à travers la musique
woodstock c'est un est un événement de
paix alors à ben beau milieu des
détournements qu'ils disent sur le plan
militaire
en asie les tourments comme au vietnam
immédiatement après la corée la réponse
de toute une génération c'est et si on
se réunissait plutôt que se réunit pour
se tirer des balles par la tête et si on
se réunissait pour chanter chanter la
paix chanter l'unité chanter l'union je
sais que ça sonne un peu kitsch de
l'hésitation c'est je crois ce jour de
réveil de musique c'était le titre même
si on veut le libellé du festival et qui
musicalement parlant un peu cet instant
quelque chose il y avait toute une série
de grands noms et de moins grands noms
c'est un peu éclectique dépareillés
c'est un peu dessus la serbie
musicalement ce que c'était cet ovni
woodstock mais en fait pour les gens qui
aiment beaucoup la musique fois firmi
quand même il faut reconnaître que votre
succès était essentiellement un festival
de blues
le genre de musique que le plus réunies
de gens qui étaient le plus souvent fait
c'est quand même une quelconque forme de
blues ce qui est intéressant parce que
c'est la rencontre de le blue c'est une
rencontre ente des couleurs à ces deux
rencontres le monde noir américain et le
monde l'américaine et on a eu beaucoup
de ça ou abstrait mais faut pas penser
que je suis d des gens qu'on a découvert
ou redécouvert s'entendait kuna on a
confirmé janis joplin on a confirmé
aussi jimi hendrix mais il y avait quand
même crosby stills qui étaient là avec
la même s'il vaut qu'ils souhaitaient la
jefferson airplane y avait quand même
des des grands noms de l'époque mais
aussi tout plaide jacques on connaît
moins aujourd'hui essentiellement
faisait ce qu'on appelle en latin des
cover est beaucoup beaucoup de blues les
beatles qui était invité mais qui ne
sont pas venus ils ont été chantées 4,5
fois dans le courant du week-end les
chanteurs de folk comme un logo de bruit
comme john boye a qui ont vraiment
essentiellement chanté la paix c'est un
bon mélange c'est vraiment je pense
l'ancêtre des grains grand festival y
compris ceux que nous avons chez nous
qui ont un nom mais qui sont beaucoup
plus larges musicalement que leur nom et
au grand bénéfice de leurs spectateurs
qu'un héritage à woodstock
mine de rien ça fait des petits ça quand
on parle de lollapalooza osheaga quoi
celle là et tant d'autres
safetic team m immédiatement les gens
avaient peur que ce soit trop moustache
soit un mauvais monterey pop parce que
mon père existait déjà depuis quelques
années auparavant
mais les rolling stones par exemple est
un frustré de ne pas avoir été présent
il y avait des raisons l'ayant nommé
giles fraser film ils ont quand même
créateur mentent en californie quelques
mois plus tard
depuis ce temps leur le monde la planète
terre est une planète festival nous on
dit souvent que le québec c'est un
endroit plein essor et en offre vraiment
partout et ça confirme à notre époque où
les gens vivent de façon très très
individuelle ou 70% des gens qui
habitent dans les villes à vivre seul ça
confirme que notre objectif quand même
comme un être humain se retrouver
ensemble de se retrouver au coude à
coude à côte à côte pour chanter
ensemble pour pour rire ensemble pour
pour ses mines avant d'être une fois de
sa société non mais c'est seul résultat
que nature une vraie nature c'est d'être
ensemble puis depuis et s'est mis amusez
vous ce soir l'important ce soir
guichard à vous remercier encore une
merci à les revoir merci beaucoup